sitting at over 4 million views this is
the most watched twitch clip of all
time so yeah naturally you'd be
wondering why why is a clip of a dude
sleeping then snoring himself awake the
most watched clip in twitch history well
the true story is even more bizarre than
you
[Music]
think For Better or For Worse twitch has
pretty much become a place where you can
find anything you're looking for want a
calm stream to be productive and get
work done you got it how about someone
working their shift at a bar or why not
a 15-year-old throwing a rave while
playing
Cod point is next to the more
traditional Realms of gaming Esports and
react content twitch is a pretty vast
place but despite all that despite all
the crazy you can find without even
having to look that hard the most
watched clip of all time isn't really
any of those things the most watched
clip in twitch history is a man snoring
away on his couch abruptly waking up
then laughing and recently I've become
obsessed with the clip and The Man
Behind it Jesse D streams fittingly
titled The Awakening the clip's origin
dates back all the way to January of
2019 and has since become a part of
twitch's Greater lore with nearly a
million views more than its next
competitor and yes the simple answer to
why it's so popular could just be well
of course it is this is Twitch after all
and out of all the things it could be of
course it's just a dude sleeping but
that isn't a good enough answer for me
so I went to the source himself to ask
what he makes of this seemingly
life-changing event and to get to the
bottom of what actually happened Jesse
started off as a small and humble
streamer who started going live in March
of 2018 pretty much playing anything he
felt like to the half a dozen people who
would hop in his chat but as an
emergency medical dispatcher Jesse had
other priorities this was simply a hobby
to unwind after what I can only assume
is a pretty taxing job that being said
Jesse still did care about the art of
streaming and wanted to figure out ways
to separate himself from others while
still being able to have those genuine
conversations he so loved thus the
format of chilling on the couch was born
and when I started streaming I I I kind
of did this two-part series type deal um
I would stream a game stream something
on like the computer and doing this and
then I had this idea where if I just
streamed myself watching TV you know and
and I was I basically called called it
chilling on the couch um and and I
started that after kind of like an after
hours type deal where we could talk
about anything we could have this
conversation between people so yeah
after long days of facilitating medical
help to those in desperate need Jesse
was just looking to chat but on top of
working long hours Jesse and his wife
were also moving at the time so he was
pretty tired during a lot of these
streams now mix that with a comfy couch
Chill Vibes and you might just fall
asleep but unbeknownst to Jesse who was
unconscious the Australians were wide
awake and they thought this Wasing
hilarious after the Aussies circulated
Jesse stream online hundreds upon
hundreds of people began to pour in to
watch a man sleep upright and after the
group dwindled down to about 200 still a
lot more than Jesse was used to he
finally woke up understandably confused
I'm in shock yes I am there's
23 people here
holy I'm just like oh crap you know
turn off the
stream but at this time this the chat
was just going and going and going and I
was like what's going on and I you know
lean over to try to figure out what was
going on and then realized holy crap
there's a whole lot of people that are
here and it got explained to me what
what had happened and I'm and it just
snowballed from there um it was front
page Reddit it was front page like
number one trending and live stream
fails so even at that point to me you
know nothing had ever happened like that
to me before so that was Larger than
Life In My Eyes personally um but when
it
hit a million views I was like you know
what is going on here now as Jesse
explained to me this was hardly the
first time he fell asleep on stream but
for whatever reason this one was The
Perfect Storm and went absolutely viral
after hitting live stream fails by the
end of the year Jesse gained over 4,000
new followers his Infamous clip became
the most watched in twitch history and
he gained a free mattress for his
efforts for the while I I believed it
wasn't real but apparently Temperpedic
saw
it and reached out and actually gave and
gave me a bed to and and I can still say
that I'm sleep sponsored by Temper
Pedic because of the of the mattress
that they gave us and and they they said
you know we want streamers to have a
healthy sleep and um it looks like you
might need a healthy sleep so we want to
give you a mattress but why why did this
end up becoming at least in the English
language category the most watch clip of
all time I have my own theories first
off people falling asleep and snoring is
all always funny plus there's something
calming about seeing a grown man hit the
snoy me like that but more importantly I
think there was some sort of secondhand
anxiety that got people to tune in in
the first place now of course plenty of
people sleep on stream in fact it's one
of the less weird things people get up
to these days even Jesse himself turned
it into a bit of a recurring theme this
time intentionally but back in 2019 the
idea of unknowingly falling asleep was
pretty scary broadcasting yourself to
the world without being aware is almost
nightmare fuel obviously Jesse was just
sleeping and nothing weird actually
happened but one can only imagine what
it'd be like to forget to turn off your
stream and go about your day but I had
to ask Jesse and he had his own
explanation one that's a lot more
wholesome than mine during a time where
everyone was gunning for attention doing
increasingly wild things here was
something real something that couldn't
be scripted a human at their most
vulnerable I think that it's part of the
wholesomeness as you mentioned but it's
just a a
genuine and true reaction to being so
surprised it's something that you can't
fake it's something that you
can't try to
script and I think at specifically at
that
time and in in the subsequent months and
even years after I think people were so
used to scripted stuff used to planned
out you know okay I'm gonna sit here and
you're going to you're going to come in
and you know do this and I'm going to
react this way and you know I think it
was such a wholesome true genuine
reaction and I think people were craving
that and striving for that so yeah maybe
this clip got so popular because it it's
funny maybe it got popular because it's
the most honest thing that's ever
happened on the platform whatever you
think it's a part of twitch's history
now even though twitch for whatever
bizarre reason refuses to acknowledge it
themselves but despite twitch not giving
Jesse the nod that I think he deserves
he's okay with it he's fine that this
moment never really led to superstardom
Jesse is perfectly fine with his legacy
being this clip a few laughs and a brand
new mattress I I don't really feel like
I need to add anything to it just
because the simple fact that it's me
it's who I am it's always going to be a
part of me until I die um and I just
want people to continue to enjoy that
wholesome moment for years and years and
years to come I also wonder if it like
maybe has something to do with like the
thing I brought up where like they don't
want people getting this idea of like
Truman Show where like forget to turn
off my stream and like that anxiety of
like oh we don't want people to
associate twitch of like these
embarrassing moments where people forget
to turn off their stream